hello treasured gretchen
you seem agitated i was wondering why
there are so many billionaires
and you really just noticed this okay
more precisely
according to forbes magazine there are
660 more billionaires than they were a
year ago
and it's a new billionaire every 17
hours we've now got more billionaires
than ever
we do indeed 2755 to be precise
what marvelous news for them and
therefore everyone on the planet
is it isn't it well there's been a
pandemic for the last year
and loads of people have lost their
homes and their jobs and their lives and
their liberties and it's all
gone to basically so how the
billionaires helped
trickle down i'm not sure i know how to
do that
no no the trickle-down effect
the richer the really wealthy people get
the better it is for
everyone because the money trickles down
into lucky old johnny and janet nobody's
ever expanding purses that forbes list
says that 86
of those billionaires are richer than a
year ago
and they now have a combined wealth of
13.1 trillion dollars
up from eight trillion dollars so the
plebs must be swimming in dosh
but every economy in the world has
either shrunk or slowed down
in the last year and the gap between
rich and poor is widened
ah but that doesn't mean that the sad
little people are worse off
well the richest one percent now have
twice as much wealth as the other seven
billion people on the planet combined
and half of them live on less than six
dollars a day so it probably does
look you can use as many facts as you
like billionaires are wonderful for
everyone
they don't call them wealth creators for
no reason but they mainly create wealth
for themselves
through the hard work of other people
and yet those people still look up to
them
they think billionaires are fabulous
even when they dodge taxes or tell
everyone what to do or
scupper businesses just causing mass job
losses
because if they're billionaires then
they must be very clever and know what's
best
right so bill gates elon musk and jeff
bezos know best
correct jesus's personal wealth went up
by 75 billion in 2020
if as you claim the world is having such
a terrible time
that he must be really clever i suppose
i mean he certainly outsmarted his
employees
he stopped them unionizing despite the
fact that many of them have to pee into
bottles and poo into plastic bags at
work
there are even friendly twitter bots
telling the world how great it is to
work at
amazon which is ironic why
well fairly soon most amazon jobs will
be done by machines
well how's that going to help the
millions of ordinary people whose lives
have gone down the toilet
they won't have to pee in a bottle in
fact they won't even have a pot to piss
in